already the most famous road in Nice the
promenade des anglais is perhaps now the
most infamous as well the scene of this
terrible Bastille Day terror attack it's
been reopened a symbolic return to
normality but nationwide uncertainty
about security is anything but normal
while the investigation into the attack
and the hunt for others who may be
involved or are planning other missions
against society goes on those who
survive can only mull over what's
happened and think about fate and how it
saved them from being hurt or killed
Nadal alcohol was looking for a cash
machine and left the nice promenade as
the truck passed behind him moments
earlier he was in its path you hear the
words terror and you see these
atrocities on the news but until we all
you're actually hear the words Harry
it's just a word the actual feeling the
emotion and when you're running we
didn't know what the situation was we
know I saw motorbikes flying around we
didn't know if people were on the back
of motorbikes with guns we didn't know
if there are the people with with bombs
or weapons and even the French police
they were there was so edgy and nervous
there were two arms officers with
pistols walking around really nervous
and the next thing some of these on the
ground they're pointing guns at him
turns out just to be just a local
tourist band members Jill and Ilana had
just finished their set when the
terrorists struck they jumped over a
seawall trying to get away we go on the
beach within the restaurant and just
lock the door and wait and with lots of
people within yeah yeah was full and so
what as it happened
people were trying to run away but also
to side
I'm gonna move with what were people
saying I don't know I just cream and and
run and people we're shocked a very
shocking the seafront attack brought
chaos Denise but it's also exposed the
vulnerability of all public places the
use of cars and trucks to carry out
terror attacks is not that uncommon what
is becoming increasingly self-evident of
France Western governments and the
United States is that if they are trying
to stop a committed terrorist but
perhaps no co-conspirators it's actually
an impossible task the warnings of
terror attacks across Europe and indeed
further afield have been repeated
constantly for months now around the
globe countries are reviewing their
security readiness but in reality as
gloomy as it may seem most conclude more
attacks are inevitable
Stuart Ramsey Sky News nice